the prime minister said we have severed
the link between infection and serious
disease and death
not only is this not true madame deputy
speaker but it is dangerous and it's
dangerous to line the pandemic
and i'm disappointed that the prime
minister has not come to the house
to correct the record and to correct the
fact that he has lied to this house and
the country
over and over again
order i'm i'm sure that the um
the member will um reflect on
um her words she's saying perhaps
correct the record
madam deputy speaker what would you
rather a weakened leg or a severed
leg you know at the end of the day the
prime minister
has lied to this house time and time
again and it's funny that we get in
trouble in this place for calling out
the lie
rather than the person lying order order
order
order can you re
please please reflect on your words
and withdraw your remarks deputy speaker
i've reflected on my words and somebody
needs to tell the truth in this house
that the prime minister has lied
under the power given me by standing
order number 43
i order the member to withdraw
immediately from the house for the
remainder of the day's city